now make no mistake we have been very
clear peaceful protesting surrounding
this horrific death of George Floyd are
warranted and substantial and the right
thing to do nobody likes what they saw
and he's in a country now that is split
this is not Republican Democrat this is
not conservative liberal universally
except for maybe a few key Boyd Ward
warriors down in their basement and
their underpants we're all in agreement
that that foot that knee on that neck
for that a sustained period of time is
unacceptable it is a death sentence for
somebody period end of sentence anger
grief surrounding that video is
appalling something all Americans feel
tonight Floyd was handcuffed on the
ground when the Minneapolis officer
Derek Shelvin applied lethal pressure to
the most vulnerable part of the human
body the neck it went over eight minutes
smashing his face into the pavement
while screaming that he cannot breathe
we get to the autopsy in a minute we now
discovered that there were facial scars
that's how that's how pinned down he was
to that pavement unfortunately other
police officers could have stepped in
and did not why we haven't heard from
them yet we need to according to this
independent autopsy conducted by dr.
Michael Biden George Floyd was killed by
that act a matter of fact is now a
report out of the examiner's office in
Minnesota that says the same thing but
the preliminary report said just the
opposite we know the president has asked
for an expedited investigation from the
very beginning and that includes the
Department of Justice the FBI the Civil
Rights Division coordinating with local
police departments in the area and local
law enforcement officials justice will
be served
already Chauvin has been charged with
third-degree murder and manslaughter the
other officers stood by did nothing to
stop him they have all been fired more
state charges and federal charges could
be on the way President Trump has
directed the DOJ to go forward with that
civil rights investigation that means
yes federal charges very possible in
this case sadly now the life and death
of George Floyd is
getting overshadowed by criminals
anarchists those looting and burning
groups like Antipa who were wreaking
havoc on the streets of our cities at
this point hundreds of businesses now
have been utterly destroyed storefronts
smashed in fires burning out of control
looting in many great American cities
business owners violently attacked
Rochester New York
a woman was savagely assaulted by an
angry mob of young men who are
vandalizing her store a man in Dallas it
just this is unconscionable
he was beaten unconscious dozens of
Secret Service agents protecting the
White House they were injured by rioting
rioters throwing projectiles in that
case police officers across the country
faced similar injust injuries one nyu
trained lawyer arrested now for hurling
a Molotov cocktail at the NYPD st.
Patrick's Cathedral in New York City was
too faced with curse words and BLM spray
painted onto the stone these historic
st. John's Church in DC what we call the
Church of the president's that was lit
on fire the president made a visit there
later this afternoon and believe it or
not this is just one small part of the
unacceptable level of violence and
Anarchy from this weekend's riots take a
look
we support the right of peaceful
protesters
and we hear their pleas what we are now
seeing on the streets of our cities has
nothing to do with justice or with peace
I saw people converging on the police
vehicle
I saw people throwing things at the
police vehicle that is not peaceful
protests
[Applause]
[Music]
this is not in the spirit of Martin
Luther King jr. this is chaos
let me be clear what we are all
witnessing as a country is a fundamental
failure of liberal governments liberal
governors liberal mayors all across the
country
Philadelphia Minneapolis Chicago New
York Los Angeles San Francisco Oakland
and other major cities now ravaged by
chaos well they've been run by Democrats
for decades the first line of defense
that would be the governor's that would
be the mayors that would be local police
departments surrounding the police
others simply Police Department's state
troopers that get called up state
Guardsmen get called up and then of
course they always had at their ready
the president who's been saying now for
some time he has the National Guard
ready for anybody that will ask for it
that is their role to ask but now the
president has stepped up and the
president said if you don't control it I
will the infrastructure in these cities
has been crumbling for decades the
school systems in these very same cities
they have been failing our children our
American family for decades they have
now failed generations of children in
many cases the violence is completely
out of control
and has been even before all of this
happened already in Chicago 200 murders
this year and we're not even halfway
through the year this has been going on
now for years why hasn't that problem
been solve
democratic mayors and governors in these
cities in these states they make a lot
of promises every two years every four
years they spend a lot of taxpayer money
they tax their citizens to death but
even after death but when they're needed
guess what when they're most needed
nowhere to be found just like they blew
it and we're not prepared at all for
coronavirus and states like New York New
Jersey Pennsylvania and Michigan well
Donald Trump bailed them out there they
know about Antipa and they know about
these anarchists they knows the risk
that they pose they
have let this build and build and build
and do nothing to stop the violence
maybe on night one they could have said
they weren't prepared what's your excuse
for nights 2 3 4 & 5 they new cities are
vulnerable to looting and violence
during times of unrest yet they're
totally unprepared for anything as
always this is beyond an epic fail and a
disgrace and a total complete
dereliction of their duty so how do you
let rioters burn down a police station
not one but two how do you let them loot
store after store after store how do you
let them destroy already struggle
struggling businesses all across the
country when by the way all week when
your people were getting beaten in the
streets where were you where was your
plan why did the police retreat
why didn't you restore order there was
no plan a spectacular failure on every
level that is weet the damage the
carnage the records now will go on for
years as a result of this this chaos
needs to end it needs to end now and as
America's Mayor Rudy Giuliani will join
us later told us on Friday if the first
person throws a stone they get arrested
the second person who throws a stone
gets arrested the third person they're
likely not going to throw that stone
because they know there will be real
consequences people need to know there
will be real consequences and by the way
passive policing during a riot is never
gonna work
dispensing large crowds well it's not
brain surgery it's not fun making
arrests confronting agitators not easy
work but these governor's these mayors
must authorize well it's simple you set
up a small perimeter you enforce if you
have curfews you enforce them
overwhelming non-lethal force including
every tool at their disposal built
around the perimeters and then of course
you use what's necessary safely to
disperse the crowd not brain surgery
that would mean teargas mace if
necessary rubber bullets if you have the
police in place the perimeter small
enough they will disperse and by the way
if they needed additional help the
administration has been
for days they will send the help that
they need now the president well he will
go in and clean up their mess just like
he handled their lack of preparation for
pandemics as well as Andrew McCarthy
pointed out in a recent article the
president has the constitutional
authority and power through the National
Guard and of course our military it's
called the insurrection act he has the
full authority to go into these states
and restore order which he now must do
because they didn't do it
if these liberal mayors and governors in
most cases are unable and unwilling to
protect their own citizens the federal
government will take a look but we
cannot allow the righteous cries and
peaceful protesters to be drown out by
an angry mob I will fight to protect you
I am your president of law and order
that is why I am taking immediate
presidential action to stop the violence
and restore security and safety in
America mayors and governors must
establish an overwhelming law
enforcement presence until the violence
has been quelled if a city or state
refuses to take the actions that are
necessary to defend the life and
property of their residents then I will
deploy the United States military and
quickly solve the problem for them and
moments ago the president walked to the
scene of this weekend's unrest in
Washington DC or nation's capital he
stood outside the damaged st. John's
Church and he reassured Americans this
will be solved